the first ever dog has been cloned in
England and we've got a picture of the
cloned dachshund Minnie Winnie
there's Minnie Winnie that is the first
cloned dog out of Britain very exciting
how do they do it let's find out the so
I'm biotech firm took a tissue sample
Winnie had stored in the liquid nitrogen
as it was transported to South Korea
upon arrival cells from the tissue
sample were put into eggs from a donor
of the dog from the same breed creating
a cloned embryo the embryo is then
implanted into a surrogate dog and
Minnie was born later by c-section all
right there's a little a little science
for you
clone dogs we we knew this was coming
clone dogs one hundred thousand bucks by
the way yeah does that seem how do the
price tags steep that seems a lot for
the cool I mean you could go to a rescue
and grab one for ten bucks with
vaccinations yeah you could get ten
exactly they'll give you gladly you're a
big dog guy hundred thousand bucks for a
cloned dog too much no I mean a dollar
first long dogs too much because you're
such a rescue guy I mean and yeah but
you you have had dogs that you love and
their family I've had dogs that I love
in the family but you have the other
kind of animal and explicably that you
how are you a cat woman look oh then
this I have to change my notes here cuz
I was gonna read about some cats please
bring it they're they're lovely
creatures if they hate you there's
probably a good reason but you were
saying the look there are it's not a
little thing there's the words of
shelters are overrun they're killing
dogs across the country on a regular
basis like if you love dogs like this
woman does and she loves Winnie and
that's great and when he's 12 and when
he's gonna die get another dog you owe
it to winning to Ken as many dogs as you
can comfortably take care of if you're a
dog person like I I got a dog three
weeks after the greatest dog in the
world rookie died or four weeks after he
died and I got it because I you know I
won I was lonely but to I like felt like
I'm supposed to have to
I'm supposed to take care of a dog yeah
and I thought you know whatever in my
lame way rookie would want that
mostly rookie would was wanted for
tradition to be honest but all those I
said I just thought that was important
and and so don't clone a freaking dog
for a hundred thousand dollars did these
great dogs go get them don't take care
of right so we've already got the
breeders doing this in there as you said
they're putting down literally thousands
of dogs every day well and they're also
saying there is there is absolutely no
not even close to a guarantee that this
dog is gonna be anything like the dog
you remember yeah nothing it's tissue
but the way you treat it the way it's
brought up that it's it has it will have
different brain chemistry right so it's
like they didn't even see multiplicity
the first one was kind of like Michael
Keaton God the worst but yes that is a
good point because all of us if you were
thinking you were gonna clone a human
then wouldn't its experiences and its
life experiences my dog is is a rescue
from New Orleans after Katrina I think
she lives through some crazy [ __ ] that
now made her as sweet and great as she
is if I was to clone her I have no
reason to believe she would be anything
did you just as a side note did you have
like a $20 bet with something that you
could work Michael Keaton into today
show yeah with Michael Keaton Michael
gave me and Michael York but I mean that
that's I think it's the logical next
question when you talk about doing this
with animals if you god forbid lost a
child at a young age and someone said
hey we could give you another shot at
this kid yeah what do you do well is
there an ethic difference an ethical
difference between doing this with
animals and doing it with humans because
obviously the next step in this and
we're gonna it's gonna happen in our
lifetime will be humans yeah of course
there's a difference I love dogs but
they're dogs they don't have soules been
that were you telling me dogs don't have
souls they have their souls are
different anyway I love Bob Bob's a good
girl but didn't Bob kill a cat no NOPD
killed okay to kill a cat he just ate
toward the toes off it's just my thought
that's so much worse just jump through a
car one
no and fit the toes off oh yeah
are you serious oh man
yeah it was boo boo is pre Ben was
before I had all of them well you say
right here now that you will not go in
that dog like a geyser
yeah like Shh you're not going okay cat
doesn't mean you should do what you're
not gonna call that dog I'm not gonna
come on I'm gonna come on that dog not
gonna clone Petey all right I don't know
that we fully got everything we needed
to get out of that segment oh you got
the idea they're calling it wrong it's
wrong it's wrong it's wrong it's wrong
now the anti-science people